what we're going to do in this video is
talk about congressional roles now what
do I mean by congressional roles well
whether someone is a member of the House
of Representatives or the Senate or even
one of the state legislatures there's
different ways that they can act on
behalf of the people that they are
representing one way is to just be a
delegate and that's to say okay what
would my people that I'm trying to
represent and want me to do and then to
do exactly that
the other role is to be a trustee and
this is the idea of well there are some
issues where either the people in my
district don't have an opinion or maybe
if they superficially looked at it they
would want to vote one way but I as a as
a representative as a trustee I can dig
a little bit deeper into the nuances and
realize what's actually better for the
people that I represent or for a country
as a whole so one way to think about it
a delegate would get a sense of the
people that they're representing what
they would want and just do that while a
trustee would say okay what do I believe
is best either for the people that I'm
representing or for the country as a
whole and sometimes they obviously could
coincide and the third type of role is
Politico now the everyday definition for
Politico is a politician and sometimes
it's used in the not so favorable sense
but in the context of especially in a
government class a Politico is a
representative who does a little bit of
both depending on the situation if
there's something that the people that
they represent care a lot about
something that the constituents care a
lot about well there they would say okay
you know what I'm just gonna vote the
way they want me to vote even if I don't
necessarily agree with it because they
matter it matters to them a lot so there
I'm gonna be a delicate but are the
things that really matter to me or that
don't matter so much to my constituents
well there I'm going to be a trustee so
you could view a Politico as a bit of a
hybrid so with that out of the way let's
look at some scenarios and think about
whether these are describing a
representative as a delegate a trustee
or a Politico so let's start with this
first one
it says there is a vote on a bill in the
House of Representatives that would
increase
environmental regulations on major
businesses several citizens in
Illinois's ninth congressional district
have contacted their representative to
influence them to vote in favor of the
bill
however representative Whelan thinks
that these regulations will cost
businesses too much money which will
lead businesses to firing his
constituents so he decides to vote
against it so pause this video and so is
representative Whelan or Wallen acting
as a delegate a trustee or a Politico so
the key clues here are that
representative Whelan or Wallen decides
to vote against the bill despite the
fact that some of his constituents have
contacted him to vote in favor of the
bill and so here he is clearly acting
based on his own beliefs so he is acting
as a trustee he's doing what he thinks
is best for his constituents even though
they might not agree with it let's look
at another scenario in the Senate there
is a vote on a bill that would eliminate
the penny citizens in Indiana reach out
to their senator to encourage her to
support the bill even though senator
Portela
thinks the penny is incredibly useful
she decides to vote for the bill so
pause this video and think about how is
Senator Portela acting as a delegate
trustee or Politico well it's pretty
clear that she's doing exactly what her
constituents want her to do the the
constituents are encouraging her to
support the bill and she votes the bill
and she's doing this despite what she
thinks is the better option even though
she likes the penny she's going to vote
to eliminate the penny because that's
what her constituents want so she is
clearly acting as a delegate and to be
clear and this is often the case many
times our representative will agree with
their constituents and then in that
situation they're acting as both a
delegate and a trustee now let's look at
one more scenario there are two major
bills up for vote in the Indiana State
Senate one bill will change the name of
a high school in Indianapolis to Larry
Bird High School
the other bill would set aside
takers for a new state park senator
Kamath has received about 1200 calls
from her constituents asking her to
support the bill to rename the high
school but no calls about the park bill
senator Kamath is incredibly passionate
about parks but has not decided her vote
on the renaming of the high school
Senator Kamath decides to vote in favor
of the park bill using her better
judgment to decide her vote and in favor
of changing the name of the high school
to represent her constituents interests
so you once again should pause this
video and figure out is Senator Kamath
acting as a delegate trustee or Politico
well you can see on the park bill which
she supports should she votes in favor
of the Parkville she does that because
that's just what she thinks is better
she's using her better judgment so in
that scenario she is acting as a trustee
she's doing what she thinks is right and
then on the naming the high school Larry
Bird High School there she just says hey
you know what I don't have a strong
opinion of it I am just going to
represent my constituents interests and
so there she's clearly acting as a
delegate and so the scenario where
sometimes you act as a delegate
sometimes you act as a trustee this is
sometimes categorized or often
categorized and especially in a
government class as a Politico which as
I mentioned before is really just a a
term often used for a politician and you
can imagine it's very natural for a
politician to sometimes act as a
delegate hey I've got to make my
constituents happy let me do exactly
what they want me to do but every now
and then my constituents either might
not care about an issue or they might
not realize all of the details or all of
the implications and so I might do
something that's maybe not exactly what
they want and in those scenarios well
then I'm just gonna I'm just going to
vote my conscience and if I do a little
bit of both and on different types of
issues
well then I'm acting as a political